hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2012 american fantasy movie called the
brass teapot
the movie begins with a married couple
named john and alice who currently have
financial problems and they even
struggle to pay for meals to make things
worse both of them are losers in their
life
the husband works as a telemarketer but
it seems like his boss doesn't like him
that much since john has poor
performance in selling stuff
he warns john to comply with the
company's values or he will get kicked
despite her charming face and excellent
academic background alice keeps failing
her job interviews but she never gives
up her former schoolmate arnie visits
alice to collect rent money and is very
shocked when he learns her financial
condition since she used to be one of
the most likely to succeed students in
the high school alice becomes hopeless
when she learns that her bank balance
will plummet to negative when the
landlord arnie cashes their check to pay
house rent later that night they go to
their ex-high school classmates party
where jon catches up with chuck and the
couple get drunk since the drinks are
free
the next day while on their way to buy
groceries their car gets hit by a truck
forcing them to pull over when alice
comes across a mysterious antique shop
owned by a granny
she sneaks into the shop but the granny
spots her and welcomes her however when
she picks up the phone alice uses this
opportunity to steal the brass teapot
and then immediately leaves the shop
with her husband
the next day john continues living his
boring life as a telemarketer when one
of his workmates randomly shows him a
picture of his boss who is having an
affair
meanwhile alice who is preparing her
next job interview accidentally hurts
her head with a curling iron and sizzles
but somehow the stolen teapot suddenly
generates money within it she finally
learns that the brass teapot can
generate money based on the pain its
owner feels
after that she purposely hurts herself
on the other side the boss calls john to
his room where he expresses his
disappointment towards john's selling
performance thus he has to fire him
despite him having an academic degree
and has been working for the company for
a long time
the desperate john returns home with a
hopeless face
he is shocked when he discovers his
house has become very messy and finds a
blood stain on the floor
he immediately runs to the bedroom where
he finds alice is lying unconscious he
tells his wife about his dismissal but
alice is not worried at all and shows
him the teapot
john is surprised when several bucks
come out of the teapot right after she
slaps him later they learn that the
teapot will generate more money if its
owner feels more severe pain
however john is worried and says that
the teapot is dangerous but his wife is
already addicted to it the following day
john decides to return the brass teapot
to its rightful owner
however the antique shop is permanently
closed and he rethinks his decision
since he needs the money for living he
attempts to sell the teapot on a tv show
while dr ling accidentally spots it and
is interested in the teapot
however before he sells it jon makes a
deal with alice to utilize the teapot
until they have enough money to be exact
a million to pay all the debts they then
purposely hurt themselves in various
ways such as getting a tattoo going to a
dentist etc the next day the couple
finally are willing to go to alice's
sister's house to catch up where alice's
mom still cannot believe how jon is able
to pay off all the debts while working
as a telemarketer
john is offended in the lunch situation
becomes tense at this point the loser
couple have officially become rich
suddenly two weird men in harry potter
suits confront the couple and claim that
the teapot is their precious family
heirloom while beating john up they
reveal that the granny in the antique
shop was their grandmother who just died
several days back and they are there to
retrieve the teapot alice who manages to
hide the teapot admits that the teapot
has been sold and gives all the money to
them the men believe her and then leave
the house
afterwards they attempt to find the
origin of the brass teapot in the
library where they discover a book that
implicitly tells them that the teapot is
actually dangerous
alice secretly rips out the page so that
jon doesn't see the warning
after a long tormenting months the
couple are slowly able to buy their
dream house and car
they even managed to conduct their own
house party where john invites his only
best friend to taste the brand new vodka
suddenly dr link shows up at their house
expressing his interest in the teapot
but the couple refused to sell the money
maker to him and ling warns them that
they have to give it to him before it's
too late they don't care and rudely kick
him out of the house
that night alice and john are having
dinner with their former rich friends
who initially underestimate them
afterwards arnie visits them and
expresses his jealousy towards the
couple who magically become rich within
a short period of time
he suddenly snatches the teapot and then
throws it to the road before he runs
over it with his car
the couple panic but it doesn't even
leave a scratch since it was made from
high quality material they go to dr ling
who explains the history of the brass
teapot the teapot is very dangerous and
he promises to get rid of the teapot if
the couple give it to them since it
cannot be destroyed alice becomes greedy
and refuses to give it to dr ling later
that night the weird men break into the
house and rob all their money again
turns out that they don't care with a
teapot and just want all their money
since they understand that it is a very
dangerous stuff alice tries to retrieve
her money but she faints as one of the
men hits her in the head
in the morning alice cries in despair
because they have lost all the money and
the teapot generates less money than
before
because of that john deliberately goes
to a pub and challenges a big fella to
fight him he ends up beaten up badly and
battered
one day alice learns that the teapot can
also generate money based on the nearby
people's pain after a skateboarder falls
in front of him
realizing that hurting themselves is not
necessary anymore to generate money they
then go to a boxing match and hire
someone to get a tattoo
on their way home alice becomes
uncontrollable in craves for more money
she almost deliberately hits a man with
her car luckily jon manages to swerve
the car and avoid the collision alice
becomes enraged and scolds john yelling
at him that he is useless
john is hurt by her words but the teapot
suddenly produces money not long after
the couple learned that the teapot can
also generate money from psychological
pain
since then the couple keeps exchanging
their darkest secrets to each other one
of the secrets that makes john shocked
is that alice turns out have once let
arnie go down on her
john immediately heads over to arnie's
caravan and reveals the secret in front
of his girlfriend brandy which causes
the fight between the couple arnie spots
the teapot and becomes suspicious of it
after revealing all their secrets they
plan to destroy others marriage to
generate more money they deliver a
package to their cocky neighbor that
contains their dead dog who turns out to
be dead because of his wife's negligence
jon also reveals to his ex-boss wife
that her husband has an affair these
actions make them richer and richer the
heartless couple even plan to betray
alice's sister but it turns out that
they still have empathy and cancel their
plan to spoil alice's sister's secret to
her husband however alice is still not
satisfied with the money she earns and
suggests they kill a pedophile or a drug
dealer to earn a massive amount of money
from the teapot
they prepare a grave for their potential
victim but suddenly jon walks out as he
realizes that his wife is turning evil
he secretly visits dr ling and asks for
his help the doctor motivates him to
hand over the teapot john returns home
and finds the missing page of the book
he threatens alice that he will kill
himself if she does not stop after a
dramatic performance by john he finally
manages to convince her to stop since
alice still chooses him over the money
later that night arnie breaks into and
steals the brass teapot from the couple
since they have to deliver the teapot to
dr ling themselves they go to his
caravan the next day where jon fights
arnie not long after brandy shows up and
the mad couple attempt to kill jon and
alice
suddenly the weird men break in and the
gunfight between the mad couple and
weird man ensues
everyone is killed except alice and john
and the brutal gunshot allows the teapot
to generate a huge amount of money they
collect all the money and finally are
willing to hand over the teapot to the
dr ling who has been waiting outside
after that the couple decide to share
their fortune to their underprivileged
friends and move out of the city with
their old car
meanwhile dr ling throws the brass
teapot in the middle of the sea
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching